he's pitched to a 2-7 era in his three
starts this year and his last outing
allowed just one run in seven innings
pitched against the rangers let's see
how he fares here today runner goes
again swinging a miss chance for garneau
and a strike him out throw him out
double play
josh rojas caught stealing as christian
walker strikes out that'll end the
inning it's the left-hander madison
bumgarner roughed up by the angels to
begin this road trip and since he's come
off the injured list after that back
problem he missed a month haven't really
seen that big step forward yet
that's ripped into left field
he's hit for bregman as first in the
series michael brantley the d8 steps in
got the call from adam hammery and
bradley does not like it
slowly hit tour altuve he'll have to get
to the bag himself and make the play for
the double play jose altuve nice job he
doesn't even realize the innings over
he's talking to peralta about it you say
hey man do you see that oh wait
i don't know if they have kangaroo court
during 2020 ahead of correa owen two on
the corner for strikeout number two
and buff garner has set down four in a
row
man looks a little sharper here so far
in this second inning he's three and two
now to
and he altuve up getting the strikeout
anyway
there's a base hit pavon smith will
dig for third pavon hustling all the way
got a great read that time and he's in
standing up eback start the fourth
inning with men on the corners and
nobody out and here's a guy who really
needs to take that baton and turn it
into something big escobar
off the corner with a fastball
[Music]
adam hamery telling toy lavello that's
enough
and he's been ejected tory lavello he's
been thrown out of the ball game by adam
hammery and so tory will get an early
exit here and a scoreless fourth two and
two
off the middle altuve flips to correa
for one
and they get two as pavon smith comes
across with the game's first run
and he delivers a strike to brantley
that one he doesn't argue at all he knew
that was on the outside corner spotted
up well by the lefty mad bum and that's
strikeout number four
first out in the fourth
front door breaking ball gets strikeout
number five and through four madison
bumgarner holds a one-nothing lead
nick get into a double play to win the
second his first time up this is up in
the air and deep to left center field
nick ahmed
has launched one out of here up on that
porch in houston
the fifth for nick and it's two nothing
diamondbacks
and hung up there just enough to get on
to that railing only the second home run
given up all year by irkidi
this ball sent into left center field
that ball could be trouble strong the
move and what a catch by mile straw
laying out on the warning track the
speedy center fielder robs barshow on a
great defensive play
and straw chases one out there for
strikeout number six
foul tip carson kelly hangs on bumgarner
has set down 14 of the last 15 and leads
it two nothing
swing and a miss change up gets pave and
smith
so jose arquity who doesn't have a whole
lot of strikeouts today picks up just
his second his first since the first
inning now hitting 231 with 15 home runs
tied for second in the national league
and homers he's top 10 in rbis and this
may be forever known as the cole calhoun
road trip
we'll tap her back to the mound
handcuffed her katie and calhoun is safe
at first
bumgarner was lifted for this guy who
has
been good against righties this year
springer hits one high and deep to
center field sending barshow back to the
wall leaping up and that's off the wall
that ball is in play and george is
flying around second he's at third he's
going to be waved around the throw will
not be made springer inside the park
home run it is two to one
george no he knew he got it good just
didn't know how good again good hustle
by george
george springer sprinting around to get
home run number
1999 here at minutemade park could only
be for fitting if he got 19.99 and 2
000.
that ball into right field sending
calhoun back calhoun's near the wall
that ball is gone
george springer ties it up on home run
number 2000 in minute maid park history
for the houston astros springer at
number 1500
clicks over to number 2000 with that
home run and we're tied
i think you kind of called that plumber
outside ball four that will load the
bases full of astros for carlos correa
second walk in the inning issued by
guerra
carlos in the right field that should be
deep enough calhoun makes the catch here
comes bregman here comes the throw
bregman safe at home plate row gets away
that'll allow tucker allows tucker to go
to second astros take a 3-2 lead on the
line drive sac fly by carlos correa
garrett gets the strikeout strands two
but the astros get the go-ahead run
diamondbacks down 3-2 as we hit the nine
presley trying to save his second
straight game ground ball to jose altuve
the astros win their 20th home game of
the season and they take two out of
three against the arizona diamondbacks
with ryan presley getting the save in
both games the astros now with a magic
number of four could be reduced if both
the mariners and angels lose on the west
coast later on this afternoon that is
the way you want to finish off the home
season